what about looking at a particular
characteristics of both physical ideas
and mathematical ideas which is beauty
you think beauty leads us astray meaning
um
and and you offline showed me a a really
nice puzzle that illustrates this
this idea a little bit now maybe you can
speak to that or another example
where uh beauty makes it tempting for us
to assume that the
the law and the theory we found is
actually one that perfectly describes
reality
i think that beauty does not lead us
astray
because i feel that beauty is a
requirement
for principles of physics so beauty is a
fundamental in the universe i think
beauty is fundamental at least that's
the way many of us view it it's not
emergent
it's not immersion i think i think hardy
is the mathematician who said that
there's no
permanent place for ugly mathematics and
so i think the same is true in physics
that if we find the principle which
looks
ugly uh we're not going to be that's not
the end stage so therefore
beauty is going to lead us somewhere now
it doesn't mean beauty is enough
it doesn't mean if you just have beauty
if i just look at something is beautiful
then i'm fine no that's not the case
beauty is certainly a criteria
that every good physical theory should
pass that's at least the view we have
why do we have this view that's a good
question
it is a partly you could say based on
experi
experience of science over centuries
partly is
a philosophical view of what what what
reality is or should be
and in principle you know it could have
been ugly
and we might have had to deal with it
but we have gotten maybe
confident through examples after
examples in the history of science to
look for beauty
and our sense of beauty seems to
incorporate a lot of things that are
essential for us to solve some difficult
problems like symmetry we find symmetry
beautiful and the breaking of symmetry
beautiful
somehow symmetry is a is a fundamental
part of how we conceive of beauty
at all layers of reality which is
interesting like
uh in in both the visual space like when
we look at art
we look at each other as human beings
the way we look at creatures in the
biological space
the way we look at chemistry and then
into the physics world as
as the work you do it's kind of
interesting it makes you wonder like
which one is the chicken or the egg the
symmetry the the chicken and our
conception of beauty the egg
or the the other way around or somehow
the fact that every the symmetry is is
part of reality
is it somehow creates the brain that
then is able to perceive it or maybe
that's this is
just because we maybe it's
so obvious it's almost trivial
that symmetry of course will be part of
every kind of universe that's possible
uh and then our any kind of organism
that's able to observe that universe is
going to appreciate
uh symmetry well these are good
questions we don't have a deep
understanding of why we get attracted to
symmetry yeah
why do laws of nature seem to have
symmetries
underlying them and the reasoning or the
examples of whether
if it wasn't symmetric we would have
understood it or not we could have said
that yeah if there were
you know things which didn't look that
great we could understand them for
example we know
that symmetries get broken and we have
appreciated nature
in the broken symmetry phase as well the
word we live in
has many things which do not look
symmetric but even those
have underlying symmetry when you look
at it more deeply so
we have gotten maybe spoiled perhaps by
by the appearance of symmetry all over
the place
and we look for it and i think this is
this is perhaps related to the sense of
aesthetics that scientists have
and we don't usually talk about it among
scientists
in fact it's kind of a philosophical
view of
why do we look for simplicity or beauty
or so forth
and i think in a sense scientists are
many
a lot like philosophers sometimes i
think especially modern science seems to
shine away sean's philosophers and
philosophical views
and i think at their peril i think i
think in my view
science owes a lot to philosophy
and in my view many scientists in fact
probably all good scientists are perhaps
amateur philosophers
they may not state that they are
philosophers or they they may not like
to be labeled philosophers but in many
ways what they do is like what
is philosophical takes of things
looking for simplicity or symmetry is an
example of that in my opinion
or seeing patterns you see for example
another example of the
symmetry is like how you come up with
new ideas in science you see for example
an idea a is connected with an idea b
okay so you you study this connection
very deeply
and then you find the cousin of an idea
a let me call it a prime
and then you immediately look for b
prime if a
is like b and if there's an a prime then
you look for b prime why
well it completes the picture
why well it's philosophically appealing
to have more balance in terms of that
and then you look for b prime and behold
you find this other phenomena which is a
physical phenomenon which you call b
prime so this kind of thinking motivates
asking questions and looking for things
and it has guided scientists i think
through many centuries and i think it
continues to do so today
you